From the bottom of my heart
i wanted to say thank you
that is a wrap on season 2 of the witcher it
is hard to believe it's been over a year since we
kicked off this season in typical witcher fashion
in a freezing cold forest in the middle of the
night since then we've shot for 158 days with at
least one unit sometimes two sometimes three all
while decked out in face shields and face masks
and goggles and slathered in hand sanitizer we
shot in 15 locations with 89 cast members and over
1200 different crew members all bringing their
craft to life none of us has ever experienced a
television season like this before i'm sure we
cannot wait to show you what geralt and Ciri and
yennefer and yaskir and all of your favorites have
been up to since we left them at the battle of
saturn hill there are plenty of new characters and
story lines and of course monsters to explore as
well as we dig into the blood of elves and beyond
we are so proud of everything we accomplished in
season 2 and we can't wait for you to watch it
Welcome back everyone toss the coin to your
witcher they just dropped the season 2 teaser
trailer and they just announced that they
finished filming and will be dropping new
episodes before the end of the year so we will get
our witcher season 2 before 2022 thankfully i'll
be doing videos for all the episodes so if you're
brand new to my channel be sure to subscribe to
get everything there's a bunch of new casting
announcements too like they just announced that
they're doing some characters from the wild hunt
during season two they dropped some new footage
and they announced more about what the storyline
of season two will be as you would expect they're
adapting the book blood of elves which is the next
book in the series but they are incorporating some
aspects of the witcher games which actually take
place after all the books if you've never read the
books and you just played the games the games
actually start after the book story ends they
actually had to retcon what happens to geralt at
the end of the books at the beginning of the games
in order for the games to exist but as you can see
from the characters they've used the season 2 time
jump opportunity to give some of the characters a
top to bottom redesign just because everyone was
complaining about the nilfgaardian armor during
season 1 that weird strange-looking armor and they
upgraded geralt's armor as well but that may have
been also for practical reasons to allow henry
cavill to move around in it just a little bit
better there is also news about what's happening
with some of the other witcher spin-off series
that they're doing like they're doing the witcher
blood origin story which is about the very first
witcher in the timeline then they have the witcher
movie that they're also working on separately
which is about a young version of vesemir called
nightmare of the wolf i'll talk about that at the
end of the video just to remind everyone but even
if you've only played a little bit of the games
you're probably at least somewhat familiar or
you've seen pictures of or you vaguely understand
the wild hunt the biggest new casting announcement
that they made is for aerodyn who is the leader
of the red writers and then eventually the leader
of the wild hunt itself he is a character that
appears during the books but most people remember
him from the games just because i think more
people encountered his character through the wild
hunt storyline the witcher 3. so quick explainer
for his character if you're not totally familiar
what his relationship to Ciri geralt and the
other characters are he's an elf that was born
to a different faction of elves that was born
on a different planet but his faction of elves
originally came from the continent where the main
version of elves in the witcher universe come from
because the world of the witcher is a multiverse
story and people travel between worlds there's
this conjunction of the spheres that happens which
basically allows travel between worlds it brings
humans to the continent and when that happens
the main group of elves develop some powerful
magic to allow them to travel to other worlds
so a group of elves travel to another planet
and that's the group of elves that airden was
born to but he wasn't born until his group of
elves travel to that other world once his faction
of elves travels to that other world they wind up
finding a bunch of humans that already lived
there they killed most of them off because
they saw what humans did when they traveled to
the main world of the witcher they're like no
we're not letting this happen again but over time
after they killed all the humans off they found
that they didn't have any slave labor so they
needed to find other people to do all this work
they also winded up finding the unicorns so within
the world of the witcher story unicorns are like
extra dimensional beings crazy powerful and can
travel between universes so eventually those elves
wind up capturing one of the unicorns and using it
to gain access to the gateway which is basically
like the train depot to all the different worlds
of the witcher multiverse sort of the main group
in charge of going around to different worlds
and conquering them is called the red riders
airden becomes their leader and when they start
going around conquering these other planets or
trying to conquer these other planets they develop
this crazy scary looking armor which is why the
wild hunt looks the way it does but when you see
him with his mask off he looks like a normal elf
he's just using magic to create the armor and to
change his voice so that's why it sounds like he's
this other worldly ghostly figure but really
he's just a warrior king from another planet
eventually what winds up happening is the unicorns
free themselves from their captivity this other
faction of elves that airden belongs to so they
lose access to the gateway of worlds and they
can't go around conquering any other planets in
the multiverse eventually they wind up detecting
Ciri's presence and her elder blood and learn that
they can use that to gain access to the gateway of
worlds again and that's when the wild hunt starts
coming for Ciri so like at the beginning of the
witcher 3 game you see geralt sort of having this
vision this dream of the wild hunt coming for
Ciri it's sort of like a foretelling of what's
eventually going to happen later in the game
there's a slightly different version of this that
happens in the books so the characters during the
video games later in the timeline that are part of
the wild ton also show up earlier in the timeline
in the books but they change a little bit of the
story there's some retcons that happen in the game
airden does wind up running into Ciri during the
course of the books what they might be doing is
just incorporating later elements of the books
or maybe giving Ciri some visions or geralt some
visions about what might happen later there are
a bunch of different ways that they could use
eredin's character during the tv show this early
in the storyline the witcher showrunner lauren
his rich who actually shows up during this teaser
trailer she actually said that she has about five
seasons planned out but they could do like seven
to ten seasons because there's so much story
within the witcher universe it just depends on how
much they want to speed run through the book story
later what ends up happening though is that
another one of these elves from this different
faction called Avallac'h winds up manipulating
Ciri trying to use her as part of his plot to
stop the white frost so he has grander ambitions
than what's happening with erdin and the wild ton
the wild hunt wants Ciri 's elder blood so they
can just go around conquering the multiverse
but depending on whether you're reading the
books or whether you're watching the games the
story's a little bit different for his character
Avallac'h becomes this really big figure trying to
manipulate Ciri who also wants her elder blood for
slightly different reasons that's one of the funny
things about the witcher storyline regardless of
which faction you're talking about everybody wants
Ciri for some slightly different reason because of
her elder blood because it makes her so powerful
and what they can do with that as part of this
casting announcement though there is a character
who's associated with Avallac'h's character and
he's obviously a really big figure later in the
games but he also shows up during the books as
well so the other big character that's sort of
associated with aerodyn these other faction
of elves from another planet in Avallac'h's
character is laura doran she's one of the earliest
carriers of the elder blood and series ancestor
like her great great great great great grandmother
many many times removed she was an elven sorceress
who was actually supposed to marry Avallac'h
and they were going to give birth to this child
who was going to have the elder blood inherit the
elder blood and they were going to use that to
stop the white frost there's this whole prophecy
around Ciri 's character her elder blood and the
white frost the white frost is sort of like the
coming of an ice age to the planet so you have
all these different factions that are trying to
stop it through different means using Ciri but
the elder blood was basically a project of these
ancient elves they were trying to create a being
that was powerful enough to stop the white frost
and eventually Ciri winds up inheriting this power
she's the last member of the bloodline so that's
why everybody all over the place within the
witcher universe wants her but it all goes back to
avalak and this other character laura doran this
elven sorceress eventually she wound up falling
in love with a human mage had a child with that
person so the elder blood project that the elves
had sort of passed to a different lineage and
sort of threw their plans into disarray they also
confirmed that they're casting ithlean who is the
person who created the prophecy about Ciri's elder
blood and the white frost so obviously that's just
a key part of the story because that's sort of
the end game for the show is doing the white frost
they said that they were never gonna do the video
game story line but then just a little while ago
the witcher showner was like well we're gonna do
some of this stuff from the games they announced
that graham mctavish of all people have joined
the cast as sigmund dixtra who's the rodanian
spymaster you probably remember him from somewhere
he's done so many big roles in the past couple of
years he's an advisor to king visamir who they
also announced is going to be part of season two
and along with their characters they're doing the
philippa elhart character who is a sorceress that
works in his court so just sounds like we're
gonna be spending a whole lot more time with
the redanians during season 2. they also finally
confirmed they're doing the riots character i
don't know if they're going to be changing him
from the books because they're adapting blood
of elves for most of the storyline of season 2
and he is the main antagonist for the most part
during blood of elves but he's really just working
for vilgefortz so we'll see how they try to adapt
that storyline remember only eight episodes so
they tend to speedrun some of these story lines
as you would expect he spends most of season two
trying to get Ciri from geralt but the whole thing
with geralt and Ciri during season two as i've
said in previous videos is that most of season
2 will pick up with him training her at cara
marin they are doing cohen eskel and lambert
the three other witchers that are sort of around
geralt while he's training Ciri during this period
you've seen most of them during the video
games if you played any of the video games
and if it wasn't clear when season 2 picks up
yennefer has been captured by nilfgaard so she is
kind of with them for a good portion of
the series before eventually she winds
up reuniting with geralt and ciri so at least
for the first couple of episodes i'm assuming
that the characters will be split up like even
yaskir is off on his own not with geralt while
this is happening at the beginning of the season
they posted a couple pictures of series training
montages so you just can imagine how that plays
out if you played the games at the beginning of
witcher 3 you kind of see a young version of Ciri
training with her sword the whole thing with the
witcher prequel series blood origin there was a
report that they were trying to cast jason momoa
as the original witcher they made a couple casting
announcements for the show for some of the main
characters but they haven't announced the complete
cast yet and it sounds like they're getting ready
to start filming that pretty soon but everyone
post all your predictions in the comments below
and let me know what you think they're doing
with aerodyn and the wild hunt characters
during season two will you wait for everything
click here for all my other witcher season 2
netflix videos and click here for my brand
new marvel loki trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and toss a coin to your witcher!